dude I was at of dinner and somebody
said something as a joke and I put up my
finger to my lips and I said I need to
write this down because it was an
incredible idea the guy goes you put his
you put your finger on his
lips and then my own lips back and forth
and um I was like say no more I need to
don't I don't want to lose this idea let
me write this
[Music]
down
so today you're going to talk to talk us
through a bunch of research products
that you use a bunch of a bunch of pipes
you call them right yeah internet pipes
I called it research tools you said that
was dumb well it just sounds boring it's
more accurate but it's boring I call
them gold mines which is basically some
people just come back and show you a
little piece of gold maybe a jewelry
Steph shows you where the mine is so you
can just keep going back to the mind for
more and more gold over time because I
think people wonder uh you know if they
see your tweets or read your blog post
hear you on on our podcast they're like
where does she come up with this stuff
how dides she find this stuff so today
you're going to tell us exactly that
yeah yeah exactly I think you know the
internet is such a special thing and we
often rely on something like Twitter to
serveice the information of the day but
I feel like these tools are like like
you said the gold mine there's so much
information that tells you exactly what
people want or um Aggregates a bunch of
opportunities for you so Steph tell me
about this patent one because there's
actually a handful of like really good
examples with this one okay that I can
that I know of so there's two parts
there's patent filings and patent
expiries so patent filings I think um
there's probably some databases that do
this but the newsletter that I like to
read is called patent drop and they'll
basically break down every newsletter
three or so patents from again big Tech
firms like Fang um but also companies
like Nike um by the way I think Nike is
the company with the most design patents
sort it's up there um
in any case there's patent filing so you
can track what these big companies are
betting on what they think is
interesting that they want to you know
retain some IP around and then there's
also expiries um which is interesting I
think uh we covered the company hyns
before and how they basically leveraged
a patent expiry um to build their
company or at least their first products
um so there's a website called patents
expiring today.com which Aggregates
these and obviously it takes quite a bit
of sifting because there's a lot of
things like okay I don't care that some
shinard is um expiring but um I think
the combination of those two uh
definitely can can result in some
business ideas have you guys heard of
bluechew you guys know what bluechew is
blue chew yeah so about three or I don't
think they target you in ads but they
target us for sure yeah basically about
six weeks ago I went to these guys'
office and I met the two Founders and
one of the founders is a doctor and the
other one was a Commodities Trader
and basically they worked together and
they were like what can we start and
they saw that the Viagra patent was
going to expire in 2017 and so they like
were just plotting and plotting and
plotting and HS gets a lot of credit for
doing this but bluee I think is actually
more interesting so what blueo does is I
think they also own med.com so it's
basically a a tella Health business
where you call in and you say what your
issue is their main thing is uh their
pill I I guess I don't know if call it
blueo the name of the pill but it's a
for erectile dysfunction which I didn't
realize it it it's like the customer
base for that is like 150 or 200 million
people in the world and then it's
projected by 20 2030 to be like four or
500 million so it's a massive amount of
people who have erectile dysfunction
disorder um and they bootstrap this
company and they didn't I don't know how
big they are but I'm pretty sure they're
between1 and $200 million a year in
sales and they entirely bootstrap the
company starting 2017 and it was because
of that patent that expired and they
built this business because of that yeah
that's it's an incredible example
another kind of one chart business all
you had to do is just show here's the
business plan this is the expiry date of
Viagra we're gonna make the you know the
DDC generic version and uh yeah they
just do it through Instagram ads whatnot
they own I think it's meds.com so
meds.com I think is the tah Health side
um and then they have bluechew which is
like their product I think it's like
seala Viagra and one other that are all
uh expired now yeah I went to their
office and we were playing poker and
they had like a sample like instead of
having like breath mitts it was like a
sample of like you could just reach it
and take one and I was
like I was like my wife had a baby like
two weeks ago I don't think I need this
but like what happens here's a room also
a padded room you could just go stand in
to see the effects and nobody will look
at you then come back when when you're
done yeah I was like I don't know if I'm
going to if this is going to like be in
use anytime soon in my house but uh but
they I was like looking at some of their
numbers particularly on similar web and
they had like two million people a month
coming to their website and I was like
doing back of the ma back the envelope
math I was like I'm pretty sure this is
a massive massive company hims gets a
ton of credit because they're publicly
traded and they're started in San
Francisco and they had all this press I
think this company is probably almost as
big and I'm pretty sure the two guys own
most all of it they haven't taken any
financing and so anyway this patent
thing is is pretty wild yeah and I
haven't gone through the stuff happening
in 2024 but another quick call out is
the public domain stuff right so every
year new things go into the public
domain we're hitting January soon and so
that's another thing uh to call out for
folks well I think like a few years ago
wasn't it like Winnie the Pooh or
something like that like like was it
Winnie the Pooh like a bunch of these
like yeah and then Ryan Reynolds uh took
advantage of that he did what was it in
partnership with one of the phone
companies and he did Winnie The Scrooge
uh as a commercial that's pretty wild
that's pretty funny um by the way
another one of these trends that you
called out a few years ago which I
thought was so stupid at the time and
I've since spent probably $500 on this
crap is you did my wife loves this stuff
it it was like minis it was um for some
reason oh like mini cooking sets and
stuff have you seen this Sean like
basically it's mostly women I think
Young stupid though I agree but it's so
I've SP when she was pregnant I would
buy her I bought her this like I bought
like a bulk case of it and then every
week I would give her like a present
wait describe what is it so it's it
sounds so dumb the the one that she
liked was called mini Brands I think and
it's like any famous brand that you know
of like Coca-Cola Kit Kat like any type
of snack but also like different
products uh like a shoe box they make
just miniature versions and you open up
this small ball it's like a it's like a
baseball size thing and you open it up
and inside there's like a variety of
like eight different mini things and
people just love I guess looking at them
I I don't even understand what the
appeal is but
children it's weird Steph seems like
someone who's into like this mini
by the way this is uh zuru so this is
that same guy Nick Mo that we talked
about on the podcast the to the toy
Mogul uh by the way he said he wants to
come on so we should uh we should hit
him up and get him on but they're it
looks like they're the makers of this
this is it called mini Brands yeah mini
Brands it's and it's really expensive
they're expensive are they edible or are
these fake like no no it's just like a
it it looks like imagine a Kit Kat bar
but just like the size of a penny that's
all it is it's just small it's just mini
and excellent I have had this theory for
a long time that anything mini just
works um like I remember in science
class there was like a mini Beaker and
everybody used to fight over it and I
was like what that holds less and nobody
wanted to hear me I was like no but that
holds less stuff and uh but everybody
wanted to have the tiny thing and I was
like what's going on on here um there is
something to this like either overly
large like kind of like the Love Sack
like either like an overly large thing
or a completely tiny thing is just like
one way to make a product more there's a
YouTube channel called Jenny's mini
cooking show that's the one I remember
from years ago where I was like people
will just watch this person cook cook
these quote meals for
hamsters and they'll do the whole thing
they'll have like a tiny little knife
and cut the pizza and the cake and serve
it on the tiny plate people love this
stuff
yeah and I can't I make fun of these
people but one time I ordered a uh a
birthday cake that was it was a Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup that was actually the
size of a birthday cake so I I just like
bigger things but I understand
like which sounds awesome right like
you're not you're GNA buy that like
right now I should make like the Cyber
truck mini basically is like the thing I
should do I should make like the really
tiny cyber truck that can just park in
your garage and that's it yeah it's
weird weird man it's weird we're
freaks I can't find this client info
have you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a
CRM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases hop spot grow
better what do you guys want to do next
let's the sports one what's the sports
dat so there's this website um that
Aggregates a bunch of reports on Sports
which obviously
uh people love Americans love sports um
so they have like a state of pickle ball
report uh state of the industry report
these cost money um so what is the state
of pickle ball should we go into that
the burning question in all of our minds
what is the state of pickall right now
um but what I did find was this article
that basically aggregated some data from
this and it don't open it because I want
I want you guys to guess what the
fastest growing sports are the 25
fastest growing Sports according to uh
um This
sfia research which is the Sports and
Fitness industry Association what do you
guys think were the top fastest growing
sports in America I already opened it
and I could tell you I wouldn't have
guessed one of them I already opened it
as well so the game is over uh but I
would have said pickle ball and and I
would have said that game paddle isn't
there like another game that's just like
pickle ball but it's for people that are
they want to be like no pickle Ball's
old this is the new new like
there's there two of them uh that's what
I would have guessed it does seem like
pickle ball is number one but number two
I would have never guessed Alpine
touring I don't even know what that
really is I think it's just like off off
country
skiing um and then I have never heard of
what is winter fat
biking it's awesome is what it is it's
like so sounds like something I need to
research these fat tire bikes are are
really popular right now so it's
basically a bike with a just a really
fat tire is what it is and they they are
they're sick looking you see them ride
by and is this sport you
know yeah it's just mountain bike riding
but the tire is particularly fat that's
all it is you know we what do we say we
like big and small things it's just a
normal bicycle with a fat tire that can
like imagine a bicycle that could drive
on a beach got it but I guess I guess
it's a sport um number four off course
golf interesting I don't even know what
that is I when I Googled it it I think
it's just those machines but I guess
they've turned that into a competitive
sport or and then number seven is trail
running I could definitely see that that
is the I I've I get so many videos on my
Instagram of trail running dude I was at
a dinner and somebody said something as
a joke and I put up my finger to my lips
and I said sh I need to write this down
because it was an incredible idea the
guy goes you put his you put your finger
on his lips
and then my own lips back and forth and
um I was like say no more I need to
don't I don't want to lose this idea let
me write this down he said something he
goes yeah I do the um the Suburban
Triathlon and I go what and he goes yeah
Suburban
Travon um you you walk you walk a half
mile you to this bar you drink two beers
and then you go play nine holes of golf
and I was like what he's like yeah it's
the subur I forgot he said Suburban Iron
Man or the Suburban Triathlon and I was
like this has legs and I I really think
that if somebody created some kind of um
thing for you know out of shape
middle-aged guys to do they'll do it and
I think if you make it if you brand it
almost like as the uh the non-fit person
Triathlon and it's got to have like some
version of eating and drinking being one
of the legs um you know a a couple holes
of golf as as one of the other legs and
then you can really pick whatever you
want as the third but dude that's the ne
next tough mutter I think that could be
a massive a massive Trend that people
start doing because it's kind of fun
it's ironic and it's it might be pickle
ball as the third one actually that
that's probably the right bet but um
this is this is definitely something
that I I think would appeal to people
what do you guys think yeah yeah and
that's beautiful
branding we're working backwards from
the brand we really don't even know
actually what goes underneath it's just
the idea of theb triathlon that I that
deserves you putting your finger on his
lips and then just just kissing him just
give him a little kiss like I love you
that's beautiful it's like you bike to
the grocery store you chug a beer then
you like I don't know run an errand and
that's the Suburban triath line and you
got to do it on Saturday mornings Steph
what's what's another one got to give a
shout out to pachy McCormick he
aggregated this this and he aggregated
this from a site called Tech novel G
which is one of these sites where I'm
just like I can't believe someone
created this um I think his name is Bill
Christensen or something like that um
who basically took all of the sci-fi
novels that have been written or most of
them thousands and he put them on a site
called technology and what pachy did is
he took this kind of very outdated HTML
site that's hard to navigate and he put
it into this database if you guys click
the link you'll see it and you'll see
that there's this first page that is
just just a Sci-Fi stats so it basically
takes all the ideas so not just the
books but the ideas Within These uh
sci-fi novels and says does it exist
today were these ideas in bits or atoms
and then it also breaks down things like
for certain authors let's say they had
like in some cases like azima have had I
think like 99 ideas how many of those
ideas
actually came to be so you can kind of
get a sense of like how uh how grounded
let's do some certain authors examples
so I'm on the idea Bank row
194 it says uh in 1911 the author Hugo
gernsback predicted telemotor coasters
and these were powered skates for
personal transport wheelies basically
yeah or like that one viral video that
went the video that went viral of people
walking but with these like power skates
that we're making them go way faster
yeah exactly so there's like they
basically break down thousands of ideas
in this database and then they say if it
was created and you can see in yeah the
Sci-Fi idea Bank tab in column uh J you
can see what year it was first made and
then um you can see things like Google
right or credit cards when they first
appeared in these sci-fi novels so for
example the credit card was first
referenced in 1888 but credit cards like
visa and MasterCard weren't actually
created until the 1950s or live news in
1889 and then you know it took until the
1980s for 24-Hour live Ms to actually be
a thing and it's kind of interesting
because now you look at all these things
like credit cards or live news and you
think of course right like of course
that exists that doesn't sound like
sci-fi but then you can extrapolate that
and probably deduce that many of the
things that sound like sci-fi today or
even 50 years ago likely will follow
that same fashion and so I like going
through this database because there are
still many things that still fit in that
category of not yet created but Dred up
yeah so we can create electric
rollerblades that just revolutionize the
way we get hit by cars
right uh what are examples of things
that that you're interested in on this
yeah so I mean some of these are
certainly at the point where they're
becoming real but for example in 1897
uh someone Dred up a non-alcoholic
beverage similar to Wine in 1897 as well
um electric bicycles which are now a
reality but I think becoming way way way
cheaper and way more important um vat
grown meat in
1984 um which is another thing coming
online but I think what's equally
interesting is to consider some of the
major Tech trends like AI like some of
the stuff happening happening in biotech
some of the stuff happening in space all
of those Trends kind of intersecting and
you you can ask the question whether
some of the things that you see that
again sound way more sci-fi than
something like an electric bicycle may
actually be a reality so I think like an
example of a company that maybe fits
this bill is vaa right they're
manufacturing drugs in space which I
think almost certainly a decade ago
would have sounded crazy what's v doing
they're manufacturing drugs in space
why great question Yeah question I think
we all have in our mind
what's wrong with doing it in like
Massachusetts
like imagine Sam in the pitch meeting
they're like okay hear me out drugs in
space what about
Massachusetts so my understanding is
that the way that some of these drugs
are manufactured the physics when you're
on Earth due to gravity and some of the
other forces that don't exist in space
results in you not being able to create
certain chemical structures and that
impacts the way that drugs can be
basically ingested or uh administered
and so there's that I guess immediate
function of being able to create almost
like drugs that exist today but in
different structures but then there's
the obvious future opportunity where
you're then creating completely new
compounds that could not be manufactured
on Earth did those guys raise a lot of
funding I believe so that's wild what a
that yeah that's beyond what I
that's beyond my my IQ that's just
pretty amazing there's like a list of
ideas that were definitely started on
like an iasa trip and this is one of
them yeah uh well whenever I see these
lists I just think of like have you I'm
not like I'm not into like Wizards and
game games of thrones and all that stuff
you know what do I say I said I play
sports I don't I don't rate Harry Potter
but uh I do like appreciate the fact
that one woman just sat down and created
this whole this whole world to the point
where there's like like we talk about
quidd we like that's just like a part of
like a relatively small part of this
whole universe this lady just thought up
and it is actually kind of been crazy
crazy to actually see some of these
predictions it it's in a weird way it's
inspiring to think that an imagination
can do this and I do actually feel
pretty psyched up looking through this
and being like damn I'm thinking way way
small and not into the future enough so
I I understand that I think it's
actually pretty cool I just spotted in
row 300
543 in 2003 smart wallpaper so Sam maybe
that's coming your way next pod yeah so
I'll look less pale uh all right you
want to do another one next gold mine so
I love this one our world in data um so
people have maybe heard of this website
it's a website that tries to aggregate
data that um is a reflection of of
what's really happening in the world so
it includes things like um data on
poverty it includes really Niche things
like I found I went through the website
and there was a graph that related to
the day of the year with Peak cherry
tree blossoms in Kyoto right so like
when when the um cherry blossoms Peak
the most like so random but they're
collecting data on this and I checked
this website a few years ago and I want
to say there was
maybe 200 graphs on here and if you go
to their our worldend data.org charts
page I want to say there's thousands of
different data points now um and so I
wanted to call out a few that I thought
were interesting but I guess what do you
guys think isn't this crazy that there's
so much data being collected I just
clicked on one it's adjusted net savings
per capita from 1970 to 2020 and you
could see like how much per capita a
variety of countries are saving it's
pretty wild Congo and Portugal not
saving a lot of money Germany and France
really great Savers so like it's just
like literally thousands of like
different charts you know Sean talks
about these like one chart
businesses I can't think of anything for
this chart but there's like many of
these charts where you can see something
and just spot interesting things one of
them is this uh population of the world
distribution so basically this is a
chart that is looking at how many of all
the people in the world how many are
young right now meaning under 15 how
many are working age 15 to 65 and how
many are elderly 65 plus and the
shocking thing about this chart this is
a one chart this is a one chart business
right here which is the elderly curve
goes from today right like kind of like
the 2020 early 2020s where it's under 1
billion it's by far the lowest you know
uh the smallest line to it's going to
cross over the young population and be
at you know by the end of where this has
it projected 2.5 billion and so that's
the biggest grower the working the
working age one kind of flattens out the
young one kind of goes down and the
elderly one has this huge Spike and so
if you're building anything that's in
the elder care that you're going to own
for let's say 10 20 years um you have
this immense Tailwind behind you which
is just that the population of people
who fit you know the customer base is
going to grow dramatically we're going
to go from under one billion people to
over 2 and a half billion people um that
are in that market and so that's a it's
you know a case to say say you know if
you go there let's say let's say it's
like real estate like if you owned you
know uh senior living facilities or
something like that you would be able to
just benefit from the fact that oh
occupancy is going to go up over time in
this in this way now of course
technology may may may completely upend
things and Ai and all that but it is a
very it you could see these like huge
trends that are going to be very hard to
reverse so uh it's hard to imagine a
scenario that we we change the direction
of these lines it would take like a
whole societal shift population level
shift to change where these lines are
going did you guys see the video of uh
it was Kim Jong-un the uh the North
Korean leader he was delivering this
speech this week where he was like
pleading and begging uh his his people
to start having sex and having babies
because the population is just dwindling
and he's literally crying like you see
tears coming down his face crying and
the rest of the audience is crying and
he's begging them please have babies
it's really it was really fascinating
and turn
though yeah thought crying in front of
some man crying in front of you begging
you to have have children St me just
light some candles and put on some uh
some R Kelly and it'll get it done uh
yeah I mean it it was crazy I I guess I
guess I didn't realize it's funny I'm
looking at this chart and seeing his
video I didn't realize how big of a
problem it is but there's so many here
which ones stick out to you Steph so I
just linked another one that I think
again is this like one chart um business
this one's hard to get involved with but
I think it's it it's the lithium
production if you pull that up I just
linked it in the document and you can
see that lithium production which
obviously is the core ingredient in many
of our batteries is concentrated in just
a few countries a lot of it's in China a
lot of it's in a few countries in South
America that's another example of just
as you're browsing through a bunch of
these these charts I think that one
jumps out but the one I wanted to dive
into in depth is air pollution so if you
click the the the stat uh in here in our
document that says air pollution is one
of the world's leading risk factors for
death which maybe is obvious to some
people but to me when I think about it's
like what are what are the key causes of
death what am I afraid of air pollution
is not at the top of that list however
um I also stumbled upon Patrick
Collison's pollution page he's got a
bunch of cool pages on his website he's
got a page just a bunch of questions uh
one of them's on pollution and he says
that the World Bank indicates that 3.7
billion people so about half the world's
population are exposed to this metric um
of PM 2.5 that that has to do with like
the size of particles uh in the air
they're exposed to around five times the
the unit of measure that he correlates
with a bunch of things which include uh
lower GDP it includes uh stock market
returns being lower uh people making
worse decisions like chess players uh
making mistakes politicians using Les
less complex speech so those are just
you know some fun facts but I think
what's what's really important is
obviously the the health side of things
and there's another stat um that I'll
just quickly share which is uh from a
newsletter called Charter which says
that India's capital um this was
recently breached the 450 mark on the
air quality index over four times the
healthy level um and basically they're
in this hazardous Zone which is akin to
smoking 25 to 30 cigarettes a day and
obviously that is an outlier but I
wanted to call this out because I think
air quality is something that um is is a
problem in a lot of places clearly um
some more than others but it's something
that I think people are going to be
caring about a lot more and maybe one
one product that came out in the last
year or so that's indicative of that
that a lot of people made fun of um was
the Dyson mask headphones so I I'll stop
there what what what were those yeah I
never saw those they are headphones that
have a uh basically a mask a air
purifier attached to them wow and
they're expensive they're $1,000 I think
right they are $700 from what I can see
and what this came out and people just
made fun of them well if you if you
Google Images it's like a white guy in
like the New York subway wearing it you
know what I mean
like it's a little off on because you're
talking about India and uh a few other
countries not maybe the New York subway
so it's kind of like a it's kind of like
a misleading ad they have but that's
pretty fascinating is this are these
taking off no I think they're in that
zone of a lot of people making fun of
them however the reason I'm calling this
out is because I think there is this
understanding that you know it's just in
New Delhi it's not you know anywhere
close to home um but I think have you
guys ever
use like a an air quality index um
measure in your home or like a CO2
monitor yeah I have multiple times and I
bought like these air purifier things
that also measure the air quality in my
house and I have them and it's like
shocking whenever It'll like it
basically turns red and it's like oh God
there's something going on you know what
we need to air this place out or or
whatever yeah yeah so I mean air quality
changes over time and I don't know I've
been noticing more even in San Francisco
a few days where people are like oh I'm
I'm a mask could work not because of
covid but because like oh gosh like I
have you checked the air quality and a
lot of people aren't doing this still
today but I think that'll change and I
think if you use some of these like the
CO2 monitor for example you literally
like if you go to bed with your door
closed and you wake up and you check
that thing it is wild um how high it is
and you know all you need to do is open
a window or you know circulate the air
in your home but I think as the stuff um
I guess is people are more educated on
it I think some of these devices like
the air quality uh monitors are going to
take off and you can see some of this
data in Jungle Scout as well of just
like the kinds of products that people
are buying do you see uh what did you
see anything in Jungle Scout that stood
out any product that okay so there's one
product which is uh has to do with uh an
AC furnace and an air filter um but
guess how much this thing sells every
single month what is it it's an AC
furnace air filter and an air quality
monitor
and so what does that mean literally
like the filter I put on the vents of my
like like I've got like eight vents
around my home and I put these like
filters there is that what you referring
to like those like the cloth almost
filters you it's a filter you would put
on your on your um furnace got it okay
all right so what I'm looking at here is
yeah like the kind of Standard air vent
uh filters that you have to swap out
every whatever six months or so but also
it's a smart one so it has like a
monitor associated with it like that has
an app this thing cost 250 bucks uh yeah
I have no idea but I you know sounds
like it might be a little high so tell
us what what's the what does jungle
Scout tell us for the I'm seeing four
entries in Jungle Scout and um they are
17 million 12 million 8 million and 8
million so what is that all total that's
like
over40 million per month this is this is
what jungle Scout is saying so you know
take it with a grain of salt I'm not
sure how they measure but um they tend
to be pretty accurate and so
that's an example of I think as people
again like try to understand the air
quality around them I think there's a
there's a growing business here that is
fascinating I want to point out another
thing so this um this chart that you
have of like causes of death so the top
uh let's see risk
factors I think I might have chosen the
United States here but in the United
States I believe the top ones are
smoking number one high blood pressure
high blood sugar and obesity so I have a
crazy story to tell you so I can't say
his name because he he asked me not to
or he said he prefers to stay under the
radar but I have a friend who is an
investor and he's a very different kind
of investor so what you see on Twitter
often is people who are investors they
like to be loud about what they do
they'll just kind of spray and pray
they're they're doing a lot of Deals
they love to be angels in 50 things
putting 20K checks my friend is very
different he says that and every year
there's
like one thing that matters maybe two
and he his old job is to just find the
one or two things that matter and so
I've known him for you know maybe 10
years now and at one time it was like
he's like Bitcoin it's Bitcoin right now
and I was like Bitcoin really like the
you sure this is like you know let's say
I don't know 2013 2014 2015 somewhere
there he's like it's Bitcoin and then uh
he was the one who was like only fans
I'm all in on only fans and I was like
only fans what what is that this is
before any before any of the revenue
numbers had come out about only fans
he's like I think and I was at twitch at
the time and he's like only fans is
bigger than twitch it's going to be
bigger than twitch and I was like no
dude twitch is like one of the biggest
internet sites on Earth and he's like ye
trust me it's gonna be bigger and he and
he's like called it basically each year
he doesn't necessarily always get to
invest but he's trying to identify what
is the thing did he get in on those yeah
so like for a couple of these yeah he
he's got the ones I've mentioned so far
he did so then he uh text me the other
day and he goes uh GP greater than GPT
uh so this is like I talked to him maybe
I don't know nine months or a year ago
and he was like yeah I think this soic
stuff is the thing for the year and I
was like really like isn't it AI he's
like no I think this I I think glp is
bigger than GPT um and I was like what
do you mean he's like I'm trying to
figure out the right way to invest in
this uh because they're all like
basically OIC and the makers of these
are all all public stock so he's like I
could buy that but the upside is not
exactly there so I'm trying to figure
out what's the move and he told me he's
like there was one company I invested in
several years ago that might actually be
a beneficial beneficiary of it so
yesterday sends me an article kmot this
uh Carmo this uh this pharmaceutical
company got bought for $3 billion
yesterday and that they are a maker of
glp drugs he was an early investor in it
he invested in it like seven years ago
or something and I was like dude how did
you get in on this he's like well you
know at the time it all wasn't clear I
can't say that I I you know definitely
didn't know about that but it was uh
these guys were drug makers that were
attacking obesity drugs in a different
way and you know just looking at the
charts about what kills everybody you
know like the Obesity is a massive
massive problem there's not that that
many interesting bets of who's attacking
obesity in a different way these guys
were one of them and I like their team
and whatnot so I invested early on and I
was like geez man like just to have like
A3 billion doll exit out of nowhere kind
of am amazing what do you think his
return on that
was uh I don't want to say but you know
he got in fairly early and uh three
billion is a big number so I think he
did extremely well on that one but I
will what I will say is that he kind of
looks at these like Mega Trends and uh
this is kind of what you're you're
showing here Steph is that if you
understand how big the wave is then the
opport then it then it kind of
simplifies life you can ignore all small
waves if you know what the mega you know
the big Title Wave are and you just
figure out okay what's the best way to
Surf this and even if you don't figure
out the best way even the fourth best
way to Surf a mega trend is going to
going to work in your favor and I've
heard this now from from a few investors
but also um Mark Zuckerberg said this a
while back like I remember when we were
we were working on some app that was
like a messaging app like text messaging
app and this was maybe 2015 or something
and it seemed like text messaging was
the big thing and Zuck came out and he
goes there's only a few Mega Trends
mobile was the last one and then the new
one is video he goes video is a mega
Trend everything is moving to video
people are going to communicate through
video they're watching more and more
video short video long video mediumsized
video scripted videos ugc videos it's
all going to video and I had never heard
anyone say this I this word megat trend
and when Zuck said that I started to pay
attention and we actually ended up
pivoting our company into video
streaming live video we were like oh
we'll go for live video and uh that's
the company that got bought by when we
got acquired by twitch is because we
were just partially in the right space
like live video streaming there was
weren't that many people working on it
in an interesting way but live video
kept growing kept growing kept growing
at this like really fast rate and so it
was smart to get out of the text game
and get on the the right Mega Trend yeah
you know something I'll mention about
the air quality stuff that's related to
what you said there Sean is I feel like
one missing Gap with air quality uh
readings and devices and all that is
it's not obvious as in I feel like most
people would be surprised to be like oh
my gosh I inhale all this stuff and it
has these ad adverse effects and it's
you know it ranks here on you know the
the likelihood of of death but it's not
obvious it's not in your face like let's
say like the gp1s people see themselves
every day and they're constantly trying
to improve their image and how other
people interpret them um so I think
maybe one thing that if if someone was
going to go figure this out you guys
have talked about um the air the water
filters people go into your home and did
they say like did you know like you're
drinking like this much of of like
basically like rocks and other sediment
and lead in your your water can you
believe it and they show you and so I
feel like there's an element of that
where as it's going to take a while for
people to really care about the air
quality stuff but there may be some
Middle Ground where some company is able
to effectively give people that aha yeah
I would put it differently I don't think
it's going to take a while I think it's
going to take a marketer for people to
care it's just going to take a marketer
and a product design that puts it in
your face and that educates you about
this and kind of scares you about it but
then says don't worry there's a solution
and that's how a lot of things get done
is you know a great marketer or product
designer figures out the way to put it
in your face did you guys remember what
Rob deck said so Rob deck came on and he
didn't spend too much time talking about
this but he said he bought a good chunk
of a company that is doing water filters
for showers and I've got a bunch of
friends that are like Health freaks so
Justin Mayers is is one of them where
he's a health freak and he's a great
entrepreneur and he was like man I
installed this really expensive
basically Berkeley filter which is that
big metal it's like those metal jugs
that you see in people's homes and he's
like I wanted to install one for my
whole home because I wanted my shower
water to also be completely filtered and
I went through this whole ordeal to do
this and then Rob jerck invested in this
company that is basically making a
shower head that is a filter so it's
ideally simplifying that entire process
he talked about that on this podcast but
he didn't spend too much time talking
about it and I went and researched a bit
of it I think that is going to be a a a
pretty big company and I think there's
going to be a whole I I imagine it's
going to be like a uh like a boxed
mattress Trend where no one has them and
then suddenly many people have them and
there's tons and tons of competition
because I don't think that's quite that
hard of a company to to to create uh I
don't know what the mode is entirely but
I imagine there's going to be a whole
bunch of people in that space and so I'm
I'm pretty much on board with with what
he said and I I think you have an
interesting Insight with the uh
particular with the AC vents that's
another product that literally everyone
has in their home you have to replace it
two or three times a year and it's a
really really easy Instagram ad to make
all right let's move let's go to the
next one what else you got all right
next one in here is Gadget flow so this
is just an interesting site uh that
Aggregates gadgets um friending gadgets
uh I want to call it two things here the
first is if you look at the most popular
gadgets you might say well what's the
opportunity here right like I'm not not
going to create a drone like DJI I'm not
going to create the next arvr device
Apple's doing that meta's doing that
like there's no opportunity I just
wanted to call out that every time
there's a new device that ends up
penetrating uh a lot of people's homes
or wallets uh there's almost always an
opportunity for accessories um so a good
example that we covered years ago Sam on
Trends was uh airpods and you have got a
crazy stat on that you've got a crazy
airpod stat it this was forever ago I
wonder what it is now but back then it
was like early on in the airpod journey
and it was like airpods if it was a
standalone company would be in the
Fortune 50 or something like that I was
like whoa whoa I think your stat was
like airpods make more Revenue than like
Spotify Snapchat and Airbnb combined I
think Twitter was it was yeah and that
was again that was in 20 I want to say
2019 or 2020 um and so now there's some
crazy stats with airpods which is just
like 70% of all us teens have airpods
like that is like true penetration um
and so early on in that Trend it's like
okay there's like cases there's um
trying to remember like keychains really
simple stuff but I think what uh is
worth just understanding or or what you
can take away from this gadget flow
website is like okay what are the newest
um devices that are not going to have
the scale of like hundreds or thousands
of people using them but millions or
hundreds of Millions what are the
adjacent accessories or products that I
can create so how do you how do you use
Gadget flow so Gadget flow is not as
much of like you know a searchable
database like something like jungle
Scout but um it's more so just what I
would do if I came to this page is first
I would look at the drop down of most
popular right so that's where you're
going to see some of those big devices
and then the other takeaway is some of
the uh drop- down categories I think so
the one that caught my eye was pet
accessories um so remember Gadget flow
is like all tech devices and so if you
go to pet accessories um there's a bunch
of different things I guess you both uh
have owned dogs I've never owned a owned
a dog but uh I wonder if you're familiar
with any of these devices and in
particular there was one that I noticed
um have you guys heard of um fluent pet
no what's that no what is it it is this
uh really interesting trend of these
buttons
uh fluent pet is particular brand um
that I think is going pretty viral
because of one account uh this dog
called I am bunny this this account has
I think a million followers on Instagram
and it's it's basically these buttons
where you can I don't know how like how
well this works for all dogs you can
kind of teach them to communicate with
you uh by pushing these buttons to
indicate what they want and I've seen
these and it's and and it is actually
really cool so the way it looks is it
looks like a uh so it looks like a
imagine like a like a twister pad and
each color has a button on it and the
one button means bathroom one button
means food one button means other thing
and you could train your dog to click a
button to do what to tell you what they
want it it's actually really cool yeah
it's pretty awesome uh I've seen these
and I I we trained our dog how to do
that where like he like I I could tell
what he wanted based off of a handful of
activities that we would teach him how
to do this is actually really cool yeah
my dog is way too dumb for this but uh
this is awesome uh by the way yesterday
I took my dog out to I took my kids to
gymnastics and we brought the dog and so
all these kids love to come pet the dog
and this kid comes up probably like I
don't know seven years old something he
goes oh your dog's so cute and I was
like thank you I was like you want a pet
he's like yeah he goes what's her name
and I go yeah her name's busley he goes
a why didn't you give her a better name
[Laughter]
and I was like okay maybe I and I was
like I didn't know how to respond I was
like man I just got owned by this little
kid what are you supposed to say to that
why didn't you give her a better name
like
Rosalina yeah it's like oh my God what I
was I was it's like I got a jab in the
nose John did you name the dog I did
name
gu what was the answer I just thought it
was a very Regal sounding
name I think your definition of Regal
and everyone else's definition is a
little bit different like like a butler
I don't know like oh busley um Steph are
you just what are you doing all day are
you just clicking through all these I
mean you probably have aund or 50
different links here are you just
clicking through this stuff all day many
Tabs are open right now uh I want to say
35 and are you gonna go through those or
you just a hoarder there's an order
there's like the jungle Scout tabs
grouped together the like similar web
tabs grouped together um I don't know I
mean I think
so I will spend time every so often just
like going through these websites and
like scouring for ideas but I think
there are a few newsletters and things
that I pay attention to that kind of
surface ideas that I then if I find them
interesting will go and check them you
know in similar web or jungle Scout or
whatever and I know you're at a16z now
and I I presume you're happy but
inevitably one day you're going to and
you're going to start a company I that
you have it in you I I think you're
going to do that what do you think it
will be which
category because you you've seen all
this data you look at all this data what
what's going to interest you whenever
you do it well I don't want to share the
ideas that I actually want to pursue
soon because which category um you could
say games um or I like the idea of you
know people we've talked about before
someone if you guys remember Neil
Agarwal Neil
fun um yeah great great website you know
part of me we talk about these big Ideas
like Ai and biotech and it's all very
interesting and you know someone please
go become the air quality uh marketer
that we all need but part of me just
wants to create things that I wish I saw
on the Internet or I wish existed on the
internet that Aggregates some of the
these ideas or gets people to learn
things in ways that they never thought
of before um and so I kind of just want
to be this is too too silly of a term
for but like an artist like an internet
artist if that makes sense are you and
you work at an investor now is this
something that you'd raise money for or
you'd want to do all all on your own i'
do it on my own you wouldn't raise money
I don't think it's the kind of it's not
a VC internet artist who's gonna they're
gonna be like do they have those in
Massachusetts
like all right well I'm just curious
Peter levels is like the internet like
the the Banksy of Internet art right now
right like he's he's kind of one of
those guys yeah exactly and I think you
will do that I'm I'm eager to see when
you when you finally do do it I think
you're going to do really well in it
well they have her trapped because I saw
her do something yesterday that made me
just shake my head she tweeted out who's
got the best company swag in the world
and she posted a photo of a backpack and
like a koozie and like a water bottle
that all said a16 Z on and no doubt they
were beautiful products it's great to
get free stuff but that's how they get
you stff I was like no they're wrapping
their tentacles around you you know
what's the the two most addictive things
of the world heroin and a monthly salary
well third is free Swag yeah they don't
even you don't even have golden
handcuffs you have a black umbrella
that's what they did for you my the
internet artist that I want to follow
that I admire does not fall into the
traps of company swag they reject
company swag they reject company swag
when I saw you post that I was like oh
no she's she's in too deep it's like an
Inception we need to wake her up she's
so far she's in level three of inception
and uh we got to snap her out of this
God well I mean I am human I am
convinced by free stuff it looks like
they got you with a book bag an umbrella
and a
poncho that's
what so for all the people who have
previously tried to coach me that's all
you need just send me a backpack and a
poncho
and well I I'm eager to see you start a
company where do you want to go from
here Sean uh yeah I think oh let's wrap
it up but Steph where can people get
more of like this type of stuff
specifically so like you have this very
unique method tier Madness that you you
know you know these nooks and crannies
you're like those people where you go to
a city and you're like I really wish I
just knew kind of like what to what tour
traps to avoid what good places to go
what's the best place to eat oh she
knows this hole in the wall where you
can enter through the through the Chef's
kitchen and blah blah blah you're like
that for the internet so um how can
people get more of that yeah so like you
said it's my seventh time on my first
million which is kind of crazy and ever
since the first few where I'd come with
these docs and you guys would be very
nice and and hype up the dock and say oh
my gosh so crazy there's so much ino in
here I constantly get people reaching
out asking for those docs and you know
an aggregation of all the websites that
I visit and how to use them and how to
internet sleuth um or I like the term to
use the internet pipes um so I'm putting
together something I don't know what to
call it maybe you guys can help me with
it that Aggregates these internet pipes
and shows people how to use them um so I
think the only thing I've done is
aggregate them and then buy the domain
internet
pipes uh but I think uh By the time this
episode goes live I'll probably have
some sort of like pre-sale up on that
page if people are what are you gonna
charge for it okay if you guys have a
minute I want I want your opinion
because I think I'm gonna do something
wrong here don't just don't use the CW
you can't say course you have to call
something else like a re I don't know
you got to use chat GPT but something
involving the word research there was
this one guy that used to really he had
a lot of knowledge he read a lot of
books he had a Lamborghini in his garage
and he too had a course so maybe you
could take his blueprint he had a good
one I mean so I don't know what I'm
gonna call it I don't like the idea of
it being a course because I don't I want
it to just be like a resource that
people go to and it's not like a not
like a teachable course or something
like that but what do I charge for
something like that I when I did my book
I did this like tiered pricing scheme
where it started at $10 and then it went
up for every like 30 or 50 sales but I
have no I feel like I'm going to end up
charging too little what was that called
it's called doing content right so doing
content right Sean tell me what you
would have done in this situation so
Steph worked at my company yeah and she
was talented at she was talented she
worked at my company while she was doing
this and I remember Steph someone came
to me and they're like do you care that
Steph is doing this and launching this
content book and I was like no why why
should should I care would you have
cared Sean and I think Seth you made I
don't know you could say what you made
but you made great money you maybe made
more than that than we were PID yeah you
did did you make more doing the book
than I paid you um maybe in the first
year and Sean what would you have said
if your employee was doing this would
you have been Pro or anti uh yeah I
would have been Pro I it's fine like I
have no problem with that I would have
had a conversation just to be like cool
where are we going with this like what's
the where does this live in your life is
this like fun project is this what you
actually want to go do then maybe I can
help you go do that in a more like I
just kind of want to know where that
lives um and I just you know obviously
you know for you Steph was like a star
performer so you know stars get like
more rope to go do things if you're like
if you are doing a mediocre job and then
you got this side hustle that's the
final straw for me right like I that
then you're not putting your energy kind
of towards actually getting a good
outcome but Steph was crushing it so you
know she I don't think we were pretty
encouraging of people to do stuff unless
they were screwing up I don't know if we
ever lost an employee because of their
side thing but I think like that was
pre- Twitter getting popular like it is
I think in the future I maybe wouldn't
have encouraged it is that it's kind of
effed up but I don't know if I would
have encouraged it but I did encourage
it back then well that's what I mean by
I want to know where it lives in your
life meaning if this is kind of what you
really want to do then let's just be
honest about it like let's just have the
honest conversation we could figure out
like what's the right pathway forward
and if you're like I just want to make a
little bit of extra money we could talk
about like hey if you just did XYZ here
you can make that here you know you
don't have to start a separate business
right if that's if that's the motivation
if you're just like oh yeah I just use
this for Serendipity and networking and
I just kind of like to put stuff out
there on nights and weekends like this
is my hobby like that's what I told
people when when I was doing things I
was I'd say you know business is my
hobby so like you know for you when you
log off work you might go to CrossFit or
you might go play go for what like what
I do is I read I write I make things
that's what I like to do on the internet
and so you know this is just me doing
that hobby you know you you do Taekwondo
or whatever you do and uh I think
there's just some people that are like
that you gotta you got to let them
spread their wing I mean I think also to
your point Sean it depends is this like
an ongoing thing forever you're going to
be writing you know doing a course every
quarter and it's going to take up all
your time I intentionally with this
project partially because I didn't want
it to last forever but partially also
because it's just my psychology to like
get something done and out there was
like I think I compressed it until like
a six week thing and I was like this is
all this is the only time I'm going to
allocate to this um and I feel like for
this this new project that I'm launching
too it's kind of the same thing where
it's like I don't want to be like doing
a course forever and people checking in
with me and have this I just have this
like little burst of like creativity I
need to get something out there to exist
and then that's it yeah yeah um your
question was what would you what what
should you charge for it I don't think
this is going to make a ton of money
because the who's the type of person
that wants
to who's the type of person that wants
to buy this is somebody like you so
there's not that many people that are
like you that are like hey I just have
some disposable income that I'm going to
use so that I can have better internet
random research tools and and like
ability to lurk and just find
interesting things on the internet um I
think those are awesome people but
there's not it's not like Mass market
right so you either got to charge a
bunch or you go the way and you charge
very little but you use you get the
value in a in a separate way like for
you what I would be doing is I would use
this as a Honeypot to attract a b like
the type of person that's going to pay
even $99 whatever to $100 a year to have
access to this
database is like somebody that you would
want to go hang out with for three hours
most likely right and so I would just
use it as like the value isn't going to
come from the the direct monetization of
this asset but from the little Community
you bu build and then the interesting
either Investments you get out of it or
you know introductions or opportunities
or the company you started someone from
this that's I think where you're going
to get way more value than just trying
to charge a premium for this for yeah
but it'll pay for her monthly expenses
this you're doing content right plus a
new thing you'll make 25,000 a month I
think we'll see yeah but like your your
needs are covered right so like you know
one way one thing I think about a lot is
like um you know more of the same keeps
me I am so you know if I keep doing
things that kind of keep me in the same
level of the game I'll never have the
bandwidth to do whatever it's going to
take to get me to the next level of the
game and so like for example I I had a
course that I was teaching maybe five to
10 days a year not much and it was
making over a million dollars a year so
that's an amazing like effort to payoff
thing and then I stopped and I was like
why cuz for me making an extra $1
million a year is not going to get me to
the next level of the game I'm trying to
p play at so I was like if I'm trying to
get to the point where let's just say
let's just make up a goal say I was
trying to make I want to get to where
I'm making $20 million year okay let's
say let's say that was the goal then I
need to like have enough like room on
room on my plate just empty space that
will like force me to go create the
thing that gets me to the next level um
or I might give things away for free in
fact if it's going to like create the
Serendipity that's it's going to take to
like open up new opportunities that are
bigger and so that's just something to
think about is like how do
you do you care about uh you know maybe
the next level of Financial Freedom of
of you know sort of wealth that will
give you more Runway more ability to
like use money to do sh the you
want like the internet art type of thing
um and if you do maybe you could use
this as a tool to like get the right
people around you and do something else
I don't know it's just more totally I
mean one of the biggest learnings from
the book was some people are like oh
you're totally undercharging but it's
like how do you deliver a product at a
price point that people are like like so
happy with that they go and share it and
talk about it and and also like yeah
want to work with you and like actually
digest the information instead of and
requires no customer service yeah
exactly where it's just like it runs
itself it markets itself that's what
ended up happening with the book and so
I am leaning more in that direction but
then I also I was expecting you guys to
be like no no no like charge more like
you always undercharge but I guess I
guess maybe I should keep it Tim Ferris
said something that changed my thinking
on this Tim Ferris said he goes I have
strategy which was Ultra free or Ultra
Premium he goes I was going to give away
99% of what I do for literally for free
because I'm trying to reach the broadest
number of people possible and I want to
over be be overd delivering I treat it
like it's a paid product but I deliver
it for free to the masses because then
on the one day and he he he gives the
example he did a um this was back when
he was doing four-hour work week and
whatnot so he's doing uh you know his
blogging for free podcast for free and
then he said hey I'm doing a two-day
kind of like in-person Workshop Seminary
thing that's that open the kimono thing
or open the kimono yeah exactly and I
think he did two3 million in sales in
like 30 minutes right because people
were like I will pay $10,000 he was like
it's it's expensive I don't expect
everybody to be able to afford this or
want to I'm not even gonna promise
anything but if you're a f what I do
like I'm gonna do this open the kimono
thing it's two days and I think he made
two $2 to4
million on that day and he's like if I
had been trying to like kind of charge
along away like let me do this little
ebook for for $9 then let me do this
like monthly subscription for maybe I
can get $20 a month he's like I would
have had a a smaller audience and less
money and so and same thing with his
podcast ads he's like I would rather
have no ad in the thing or charge an
Ultra Premium to a premium brand because
there's always room he he said there's
always a market for luxury right there's
always a market for the for the absolute
best so I wanted to make the absolute
best product and then charge the
absolute you know best price I could for
that and that was like his his strategy
um when it came to that I think Alex
Heros does a similar thing so hormos is
like look I could be trying to make a
little bit of money here a little bit of
money there do a course do a do a
seminar do whatever um but he's like no
no no I'm gonna be really in your face
that this stuff is normally what people
charge for I'm giving it to you for free
builds a bunch of Goodwill builds a big
audience and then when he's ready to
charge he'll make all the money back and
more when he finally does charge for the
thing in his case it's you know a
combination of acquisitions.com where
he's like I'm gonna buy equity in your
business at this like super super
sweetheart deal for him because he's
built up so much Goodwill and like
reputation amongst you know his
potential like you know acquisition
targets um or if he ends up doing ever
like a course or a seminar or a live
inperson thing he'll be able to charge
$25,000 per person to get in and he'll
make $10 million on one day because he's
kind of built it that way so I think
there's something to learn from these
people that play the real long game
totally I don't think I could charge 25k
for anything but we'll see we'll see if
I ever get there but um well you do you
you get paid more than that that's true
that's true so I mean you you definitely
do um and you definitely can I think
that you will eventually for sure
someone by the way I read the comments
um and I read one from something one of
the episodes I was on ages ago and
someone wrote something like wow Steph
has a really int intense case of
imposter syndrome and I was like
oh true um anyway I guess uh if people
want to find by the way I'll tell you
this now you do I remember when I was
negotiating your salary when you first
joined and you asked for a number I
don't remember if I did this for you it
we in particular women would typically
do this they would say a number and I
would say a number back or I would just
say a number to them and they would just
accept it and I'm be like hey um you
should negotiate with me um women in
particular were horrible at pushing back
on their salary for what they should ask
for and you know my company was small we
in aggregate probably hired 75 people
but I noticed a small trend of women in
particular did not push back nearly as
hard as the men there were many men that
they would push back and it was
laughable what they I'm like there's not
a chance I'm going to give you this but
I guess I'll meet you somewhere in the
middle to like adjust this but like this
is crazy I offered I was thinking you
were $150,000 year person you're asking
for 700,000 that's just ridiculous but I
remember with you Steph you were way we
gave you a lot of bumps I think over the
how long you worked with us but you you
started way too low um and I would
encourage you to maybe not for this
product but to definitely Elevate what
you should be demanding for pay I I
think you're doing all right now a16z
but that I've I've noticed that with you
in particular amongst very very very
smart and qualified young women yeah it
took me around what is it so 21 to 20
eight when I 28 or 29 when I joined a16z
so it took me like seven years or so to
actually learn to negotiate so I agree
can I tell you a a embarrassing version
of impostor syndrome that I have which
is it's not impostor syndrome but it is
what I call Michael Scott syndrome where
sometimes I felt this for like 10 years
I always hire people that are like super
smart that's great upfront but the
downside is sometimes you just feel like
Michael Scott you're like oh I'm the
idiot in the office
and uh I'm telling these people I'm
actually in their way and these people
are like they're kind of looking at me
like the way that Jim Halpert looks at
you know Michael Scott and I'm like oh
no it's happening that's that the
Michael Scott thing is happening have
you ever felt that yes I felt that way
all the time and then I realized that's
actually I felt that way for a long time
and then I realized oh wait no that just
means I'm good at hiring uh so like I
should just get out of the way Scott
would do he turn a compliment for
himself
no I felt that way too I remember hiring
people that were a older than me and B
smarter and I'm like what the are
these people did I really just convince
this person did I just trick this person
into coming and joining anything I'm
doing I feel horrible about
that one woman that's so good at what
she does um in our e-commerce business
she's so fast like literally so fast and
hyperproductive like she gets the like
she gets like three people's stuff done
in in the same amount of a day and uh
she's the one who Michael Scots me all
the time I'm like I'll be telling her
something in the meeting I'll be like
yeah let's follow up next week on that
and she's like I already sent it out and
I'm like while I was talking but I was
giving you such a good anecdote and
metaphor and uh oh you just like
finished it oh okay I guess uh I guess I
could have shut up five minutes ago huh
and I realized actually this is a great
thing just like you said Sam it's not
that I'm great at hiring I said now this
is actually the bar I only want to hire
people that make me feel like I'm
Michael I'm the Michael Scott of the
office that's actually how it should
feel when you're doing it right it
should feel that means you're good at
hiring now you just got to get the hell
out the way you did the hard part and
you're funny that's the other thing yeah
I don't know about that um I'm just
gonna quickly shout out if people want
to go find it internet pipes.com I guess
we'll figure out the price it'll be live
when this goes live all right that's the
Pod Steph thank you for doing
[Music]
this